that's the Spratly young jeezy
he has a song we said how stupid don't
be my room's got rooms and Nazis it all
the closets those are extra rows of your
rooms
see see give me the worst real estate
agent elbow right here we have a thirty
four bedroom house let me show you
around a property great pizza display
summative rolls have extra smaller rooms
in them you have to sleep in these rooms
like this very unique sleeping situation
inspired by the Japanese let me show you
to the bathroom the bathroom is great
you have a regular sized time can we
have a minute to table to sink Thanks
[Applause]
I do I feel like rap effects I'll talk
to people too much isn't that good I was
talking with my mom on the phone
and she was telling me she hammer so I'm
watching your niece and nephew for a
week while your sister is gone for a
week mom
they watch me for you watch whole week
are they paying you so watch a full week
that's a long time you didn't pay she
said no Hannibal grandmother doesn't
have to get paid to watch her grandkids
I say young mom money over everything
[Applause]
isn't that healthy
so that I get drunk and I get in
arguments with taxi drivers and I get
out the cab and I slam the door
that's not the way to win an argument
with a taxi driver the way to win as you
get out the cab and you leave the door
open
Vanessa step out coming around and close
that door why he's doing that I'm on the
other side opening the other doors and
we just keep going around
round now come on Penny Hill situations
going on in life right never tomorrow